how do hospitals determine when someone
has died David Greer is a neurologist
with the yale university school of
medicine and he led a study that looked
at how hospitals determine when to
declare someone brain dead and he found
out that hospital policies are actually
pretty inconsistent from hospital the
hospital and that they've averaged more
failures than you might expect merely in
figuring out whether someone is dead
researchers looked at nearly 500
different hospital policies a majority
adopted policies that Grier himself laid
out about six years ago but how the
policies were adopted varied pretty
significantly from one hospital to
another at twenty percent of hospitals
in one of five hospitals doctors are not
required to check their patients
temperature to indicate whether or not
brain function is normal at half of
hospitals doctors are not required to
ensure blood pressure is adequate for
brain function a portion of doctors
admitted to skipping the tests
altogether that the guidelines set forth
to determine if someone is dead and
additionally some hospitals now allow
unqualified personnel to determine brain
death a nurse practitioner or a
physician's assistant rather than
actually bringing in a neurologist to
determine if a patient has suffered
brain death and in the last few years uh
in previous years the medical
establishment defined death as a
person's loss of personhood and not
necessarily by a heart that could not be
restarted and this is a really really
big thing Louis when you consider organ
donation for example many patients find
that they are not as dead as previously
thought went on the operating table we
had the story six years ago of Colleen
Burns who was on the operating table
with doctors about to take her organs
she was an organ donor when she opened
her eyes she was found unconscious in
her apartment rushed to the hospital and
because she was allegedly unresponsive
the medical staff said oh this person is
dead but then uh some nurses noticed
that she was curling her toes when
tickled those reports from nurses were
reportedly ignore
word this became a huge huge scandal and
apparently it's not common but it's not
as rare as we might hope uh yep like I
say that incompetents all over the place
I just covered a story on the bonus show
where a father who just basically had a
feeling okay was pretty common for
parent to have that his son was not
brain dead after having a stroke right
and there was a standoff he brought a
gun into the hospital and would not let
them take his son off life support the
SWAT team brought their own doctor into
the hospital and that dr. very quickly
determined of course the father probably
didn't know this that the Sun was not
brain dead right he was responsive and
he made a full recovery and there's this
nightmare scenario of being put into a
casket right and waking up up because
you're not really dead that's not
actually too likely this hospital story
though about determining exactly when
someone is brain dead you would hope
Louis that there is an absolutely
universal policy for determining brain
death and implementation of the policy
what we're finding out is different
hospitals have adopted different
elements of dr. Greer's policy and how
closely hospitals stick to that policy
also varies not really what you want to
hear when you when you hear about
hospitals figuring out when people are
dead perhaps this is just another
byproduct of our ridiculous for-profit
health care system uh and just an
overall lack of regulation in this
country altogether yeah I don't know if
it's mean how is it related to the
for-profit then well because all of
these hospitals operate as individual
entities all I said you know what I mean
here there's not you know yet but
they're still I mean the right
regulation should still extend beyond a
hospital determining what it wants to do
but I guess up but those were decision
to make own regulations writing those
regulations are coming from anywhere
also coming from within this a lot of
time for-profit entity no no question
about that yeah so scary stuff but not
something that we all want to go
completely crazy about but certainly
something to be aware of it is going on